Data in the past used to be, you know,
BI reporting that you would look at
once a month
or once a quarter, whatnot.
And, you know, if it's broken,
if the numbers are wrong, no worries,
you take a few extra days
and you go and fix that.
Right.
And that's changing rapidly today.
Like modern tech companies
kind of live off of their dashboards.
Hundreds, thousands of people
look at the data every day
to make every single decision.
And then increasingly,
people are using machine learning models
to automate decisions
and to do things fully automatically
based on data.
Lior Gavish,
welcome to 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm good.
Excited to be here today.
I'm honored to have you here.
Lior, we have way too many things
I want to talk about.
I'm just going to dive in
to give a little bit about your bio,
and then I'll ask some of the fun
and interesting questions.
You know, Tel Aviv university
for bachelors and masters at Stanford.
MBA at the GSB.
A co-founder of Sookasa,
which first of all,
it's a beautiful name.
And I have to learn more
about what you did there,
sold to Barracuda after being backed
by Accel and Andreessen Horowitz
and First Round Capital.
Which I have to ask,
how the hell you made that happen?
Then senior vice president
of email protection at Barracuda.
And now, the co-founder
of another startup, Monte Carlo.
Lior, this show
is for young entrepreneurs.
I'm a young, hungry,
scrappy entrepreneur.
And I know that there's so much
that I can learn from you.
So, I really want to make use
of these 20 minutes.
So, first of all,
thank you for being here.
And second of all,
tell me a little bit about you.
Are you an engineer?
An Entrepreneur?
What are you?
It's a great question.
And I've been going back and forth
about that for a long time now.
I'm definitely an engineer by training.
And also I think that
that's where my heart is at.
But I did find myself
spending a lot of time
on non engineering stuff
because I've spent a lot of time
in early stage startups.
And when you do that,
you kind of get to do
a lot of different things
across the board from,
you know, from building teams
that to go to market
and also product engineering.
Right.
So, I've definitely spent a lot of time
doing other things as well.
But I'm still hoping that one day
I'll get to get back
to writing code all day long.
I'm definitely passionate about that.
You know, I have to say that
that is one of the things
that excites me most
in talking to people like you
on this show.
Because you have somebody here who,
you know, is an engineer
but had such a unique experience
both of the GSB,
then creating a company
that was sold to Barracuda.
Being a varied executive manager
at Barracuda.
Now another again,
an entrepreneur.
But saying that after all this,
you still wish you can go back
to writing code because
you are truly passionate
about technology.
And I just love that because
I think it's that passion and curious,
which leads people like you
to these huge milestones.
Tell me a little bit about
the journey that you took
and some of the decisions
that you've made along that journey.
Because it's not the typical
Israeli journey to go to the GSB
and then everything else.
But tell me a little bit about
what you have done there.
Yeah. You know,
it's been a long journey
with a lot of turns.
But I started my career
as an engineer, right.
Like I worked for
a couple of startups back in Israel,
you know, in my 20s.
And at some point there,
I felt I wanted a new adventure.
It's kind of broadened my horizons
and learn things beyond engineering.
Maybe try a different place as well.
So, that's kind of what inspired me
to come to Stanford.
And Stanford was kind of
a great experience
and a great opportunity for me.
Because I think it's kind of
it brings together
like general business training
and leadership training
and all that good stuff,
along with an environment
that's very tech oriented
and startup oriented.
And there's,
it's really the community there
is very vibrant
and very focused around
entrepreneurship in tech.
So, it was a great
kind of combination for me.
So, I spent two years there.
I dabbled with thinking,
I might do non-tech stuff like,
I don't know, consulting
or semi tech stuff like VC.
But ended up deciding
that I want to do the thing
that I love best,
which is startups and engineering.
So, I ended up partnering up
with my co-founder back then.
He was a PhD at Stanford
in electrical engineering.
We partnered together to start
a startup company, Sookasa,
in the cybersecurity space.
So, that's what I did right after school,
right after the GSB.
Wait, Lior.
You are at Stanford,
you're at the GSB.
You're thinking about consulting
or going to VC or say, no, no,
I'm going to be an entrepreneur.
And you have a friend,
PhD electrical engineering at Stanford.
What was the moment
where you decided
to start this together?
Were you always talking
about creating a company together?
Or did you just say,
okay, let's try something?
Or did you have an idea first
and then join forces?
What actually happened there?
Yeah. I know, I think
I made the decision independently
that I want to start a company.
It was just too exciting to pass up.
And I actually,
I worked with a handful of people
back then including classmates from GSB.
And, you know,
you go around between different projects
and different ideas
and there were in completely
different spaces.
Like one of us was in e-commerce.
And another one
was actually also in e-commerce.
And then the third one
was what I ended up doing
with my co-founder back then,
whose name is Asaf
and just ended up being feeling right.
Right?
It was the right team.
It was the right space.
It was an exciting opportunity
in a space that seemed
to have a lot of dynamics in it,
a lot of growth.
So, soon it ended up being kind of
the right opportunity for me
amongst several that I explored.
And that's something
I would tell anyone thinking
of starting a company.
You know,
it's worthwhile looking through
several different teams,
if you can,
and several different
spaces and ideas
and see where things stick.
Like where do you get your passion
and where you
see customers getting excited.
Where are things moving
and changing quickly.
And yeah, it worked for me, so.
So, you actually ended up spending
just about as much time in Barracuda
as you did in Sookasa, right?
Because you spend about four years
in each of them.
A little bit less in Barracuda
but you had the unique role
of being senior vice president
of engineering with email protection.
And, you know,
as a cybersecurity enthusiast myself,
I'd love to hear a little bit about
what would you do there.
And what is it about email protection
that it was so relevant
to what you were doing?
So, when we joined Barracuda,
Barracuda acquired Sookasa,
and when we joined Barracuda
we were fortunate to work
with some really,
really great leaders there
and learn a ton.
And one of the things
that happened was
that we got a carte blanche,
like go and do something exciting
and can be whatever you want.
Right?
And I think,
after three or four years
of doing Sookasa,
we felt that we were kind of
exhausting, if you will,
the market around
what we were building at Sookasa.
And we're thinking like,
what are some adjacent fields,
where some areas where
we can take this technology
and really build something even bigger
and even more exciting.
And it so happened
that those times
we're at times of great need
in the email protection space.
So, it was a time when
various types of highly
personalized phishing attacks
and account takeover attacks
and other forms of email fraud
were kind of growing really fast.
And we realized that the industry
was lagging behind
in terms of being able to address it.
And like every time
we spoke to customers,
they were inundated
with these things
and it started to get into
kind of material economic damage
happening through email text.
And so, we had this
like very unique approach,
technical approach
to solving this problem
that didn't exist back then
and kind of line pretty well
with the things that we did at Sookasa.
So, we ended up building and launching
a product at the Barracuda.
The product was,
it was the fastest growing product
for Barracuda ever.
Unbelievable.
And kind of ended up leading the market.
And we got into the leader wave
of Forrester and what not,
so, for the first time
in the company's history.
So, it was really exciting
and it was a very gratifying experience.
I learned a ton
both about the technology
and the market that we were operating in,
which is email protection.
And I also learned a ton about,
you know, building teams
and companies and learning
from senior leaders.
That's, I had to admit like
throughout my career,
before I mostly worked in
smaller startups
and I do learn a ton.
Right?
Like you learn a ton by doing.
And like figuring stuff out
and making your own mistakes.
And it was the first time
that I was working for people
that were far ahead of me
in their careers.
And I had a great opportunity to learn
and really see how they look at things
and how they do business
and how they lead teams
and all that good stuff.
So, I stayed for a long time
and really, really enjoyed it.
Even when I left,
I was still very excited
about what I was doing.
And I would probably be happy
to stay there as well.
But I ended up leaving
for an even more exciting opportunities.
What I did today, it's Monte Carlo.
I love that.
One key difference
from being the entrepreneur in the room,
you know, as you're scaling your startup
and then all of a sudden joining
and being senior vice president
at a much bigger company,
you know, building teams
that I'm sure that building a product
within a big company
is very, very different
than building a product within a startup.
What is one or two key differences
that you've observed
from these experiences?
Yeah. I know it's a huge difference.
I think one difference
which has been thoroughly discussed
in a lot of books
is definitely the kind of some form
of the innovator's dilemma, right?
Where the company
has a certain momentum
and has teams that
have been spending years
and sometimes decades
building stuff.
And that stuff brings money.
Right?
And it's selling well
and it's working great.
And like, how do you come
and tell them that,
you know, you might do it
in a nice way,
but how do you come and tell them
that that's legacy
and that they really need to be investing
in this new exciting thing
that's making no money right now,
but will be big one day.
And I think that
that's definitely a challenge
in a larger organization
that where a lot of people
have a lot of momentum going
in a certain direction.
So, that's definitely something
that I, you know,
you can read about in books,
but until you kind of go through it
and experience it yourself,
it's hard to fully understand.
So, that's one thing I learned.
The second maybe
it was definitely
a much larger team in Barracuda.
So, I learned that a lot of,
that really
it's also true for smaller teams,
but like culture wins. Right?
Every time, right?
Yeah.
Like my job, I could no longer
even fully understand everything
that we did. Right?
Like, there's so many things going on.
I certainly didn't have any opportunity
to do things myself.
But like the main way by which
I could impact the organization
was to hire the right people
and to put together a, you know,
a framework or an environment
that would make them successful.
So, in the culture.
So, that was huge as well, so.
Very, very cool.
Lior, we don't have much time.
But the most exciting opportunity now,
Monte Carlo.
At first, when I saw
that you work in Monte Carlo is,
I'm like okay,
"Is he building the poker chips
that I enjoy playing
with my friends on Friday nights?"
I'm assuming that it's not
that I know that it's all about data.
So, tell me a little bit
about Monte Carlo
and the decision to leave
the incredible role
of senior vice president in Barracuda
to again be a young entrepreneur.
Yeah. I know poker chips
is definitely one of the ideas
we were considering at the time.
We decided to go for data.
I don't know.
Time will tell whether
that was the right decision.
We'll see.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's early.
But what we do,
so, we're definitely in the data space.
Our customers, our data teams
so, we have data engineers
and data analysts
and sometimes data scientists.
And we help them
with a buzzword called observability.
So, it's the idea of being able
to make systems reliable.
And I'll try to explain that.
So, you know,
maybe the way to think about it is,
especially if you've been in engineering
is, you know, 20 years ago,
if you even had a website
and it was broken and went down,
nobody cared. Right?
Like you might call someone in marketing
to take a look at it the next day.
Today, any sort of business
is strongly reliant on digital
and on online applications
and websites.
And if something gets broken,
you know, someone's going
to wake up at night to fix it.
And in fact, multiple people
and it'll be a CEO level issue. Right?
And we think the same thing
is happening to data. Right?
Data in the past used to be, you know,
BI reporting that you would look at
once a month or once a quarter whatnot.
And, you know, if it's broken,
if the numbers are wrong, no worries.
You take a few extra days
and you go and fix that.
Right.
And that's changing rapidly today.
Like modern tech companies
kind of live off of their dashboards.
Hundreds, thousands of people look
at the data every day to make
every single decision.
And then increasingly,
people are using
machine learning models
to automate decisions
and to do things
fully automatically based on data.
And data is also
becoming the product
for a lot of companies. Right?
They might be serving data
to their customers as their service.
And so, the reliability of that data,
the accuracy of that data,
the correctness of that data
is becoming important.
And it's no longer something
that you're you know,
you're calling someone
and they might take care of it
a few days later.
It's something that you need
to take care of in real time.
You need to make sure
your data is reliable.
And in the same way
that there's a lot of methodology
in software engineering,
a lot of tooling,
you know, tools like Datadog
and New Relic and AppDynamics
to manage, you know,
the reliability of applications.
We're helping teams with managing
the reliability of their data products
of reporting, of models, of analytics.
So, that's what we're working on today.
I love that.
Lior, it's such an exciting journey.
What are some of the biggest insights
that you're taking with you
from Sookasa in the early stages
now to Monte Carlo?
You know, the things that
if you hadn't done Sookasa,
you probably wouldn't know
or you wouldn't believe
if others would tell you.
Yes.
It's a good question.
I hope I learned a few things.
The main why I think,
I think at Sookasa
one of, you know,
looking back in hindsight is 2020,
we were building essentially
a security layer for Dropbox.
Dropbox back then was taking hold
and it was becoming very popular
and we felt that businesses
will need ways to secure Dropbox
and make it more appropriate
for confidential
or sensitive information.
So, that's what we were working on.
It was an exciting opportunity.
We had kind of early success
and we pretty much dominated that market.
We were,
Dropbox is our number one partner.
And if you needed security for Dropbox,
Sookasa was your go to solution.
And it was all very exciting.
However,
I think that we were so focused on that
specific niche in the market
that we overlooked
even larger opportunities
that existed back then.
A category that was later
that later became CASB,
was happening back in the time.
And we could have gone in that category.
It was a natural extension
of what we were doing.
And we didn't.
We were super focused,
laser focused on optimizing
for our niche.
And that ended up
being a mistake, right?
Like the CASB market ended up
being much larger
and much more interesting
over the long term.
And I think what I learned from that was,
you know, you have to be
laser focused on what you're doing.
Make your customers happy.
And make one customer happy,
then make 10 customers happy, etc.
And at the same time,
you want to be
attentive to what's going on
and be willing to change course
and expand the definition
of what you're doing
and see where things are going
and where the
kind of broader market is shifting.
And I think that's one
of the biggest things I took away.
Like at the end of the day,
if you want to build
a really large company
and that's our goal with Monte Carlo,
we're here to, you know,
to build a unicorn or a decacorn
or whatever it is,
an industry changing company.
And to do that,
you really need to see things
in a broad way.
It's not enough to build like a feature,
or like highly satisfy
a very narrow need.
You try and need to build,
in this case,
we're trying to build a category.
So, that's kind of what I took away
to keep your eyes open
to category building opportunities
that end up being much more exciting.
I love that.
Lior, thank you so much for the time.
I know how busy you are
and I appreciate it so much.
This is an insightful
and it's an honor to have you here.
What are three words
that you would use
to describe yourself?
Oh, wow.
It's a great question.
I'm probably,
I've been told, right?
I don't know how to describe myself.
But I've been told I'm quiet.
So, that's one thing.
I don't speak much.
I've been told I'm fast.
I do things very fast.
And that's been helpful
in my entrepreneurial career.
Sometimes it's more important to be fast.
And I've also been called stoic.
Stoic.
So, that's it for you.
Yeah.
I love that.
Lior, thank you so, so much.
Really, really great.
I appreciate
you taking the time to do this.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
You too, Michael.
Great talking to you.
Thank you very, very much.